hey guys it's Jonah here I recently
completed my first half marathon run in
under two and a half hours and it is
kind of a big deal for me because I'm
not a runner and to be honest I do find
running to be boring and I'm the kind of
person that will constantly be looking
at my watch checking the time and
thinking is it over yet
you know have I run far enough and why
is it taking so long do let me know if
you're the same in the comments below
so when I told my friends that my secret
to keep on running is to listen to
audible they were like what yup I listen
to audiobooks during my training and
also for the actual marathon it really
got me into the zone and I was so
interested in the subject I wasn't even
thinking about the time and in fact I
was able to run faster and further so if
you're training for an upcoming marathon
and you struggle to keep running try
listening to audible audible is
currently offering a 30 day trial and
you can get your first audio book for
free by going to audible.com/veritasium
my description box my favorite has to be
the health and fitness section so after
the body book by Cameron Diaz I started
listening to her second book the
longevity book and it really got me
thinking about how I want to feel and
look as I get older I'm sure all of us
would want to age gracefully and I
believe that it is never too young to
start looking after yourself so I want
to share with you how you can
potentially look like from the age of 20
to 80 if you stay active eat well and
basically invest the time and effort to
look after your well-being and what you
can potentially look like from the age
of 20 to 80
if you eat crappy food live a sedentary
life and basically abuse your body the
fit woman in her 20s
you typically weigh between 45 to 60
kilos your body fat is between 18 to 22
percent you'll have a high metabolism
excellent strength
Minar and flexibility you'll have a slim
and toned looking body and if you
continue to stay active and do strength
training your voice will stay healthy
for years to come the sedentary woman in
her 20s you typically weigh between 50
to 65 kilos your body fat is typically
between 23 to 30 percent because you're
still young you'll also have a high
metabolism you may look great and are
able to maintain a slim figure but your
body is already going through subtle
changes such as a slight increase in
body fat decrease in muscle mass and
matter Bala great if your goal is to
lose weight at this age it is very easy
to lose weight and you will see quick
results the fit woman in her 30s your
body fat is between 20 to 24 percent you
will still look and feel as fit as in
your 20s you will start to experience a
slight decrease in metabolic rate and
increase in body fat but you're able to
maintain your muscle mass thanks to
regular exercises the sedentary woman in
her 30s your body fat is typically
between 24 to 32 percent people who are
physically inactive can lose as much as
3 to 5 percent of their muscle mass per
decade after the age of 30 you'll notice
a drastic weight gain even though you
may not increase the amount of food you
eat over the years that's because your
metabolic grid was start to slow down
hence the drastic increase in body fat
what's worse is that you'll start to
store body fat around the midsection
tummy hips and thighs which is often
linked to many cardiovascular and
metabolic diseases you'll start to feel
your age stiffer lack of strength and
energy once you hit your 30s your
metabolism will start to slow down you
should reduce your calorie intake by 150
to 200 calories even if you are
physically active
don't try to lose weight fast it will
make you look few years older because
your skin will become loose and wrinkled
the older you become the slower you
should lose weight at this
age you should use no more than four to
five pounds a month the fit woman in her
forties your body fat is typically
between 23 to 27 percent even if you are
active you will still experience a
noticeable muscle loss and also a slight
gain in body fat you will notice a
slight drop in strength and stamina for
instance you may not lift as heavy or
run as fast as you used to
although you may experience some
compression of the vertebrae in your
back having excellent muscular strength
would keep your posture upright and you
will still stand tall because you are
active and include strength training
exercises you will keep it once healthy
and prevent osteoporosis the sedentary
woman in her 40s your body fat is
typically between 28 to 34 percent if
you continue to eat like your younger
days and do no exercise you will
continue to experience rapid weight gain
you will feel heavier weaker slower and
stiffer due to poor posture and
compression of the vertebrae disks
you're more likely to be one to
one-and-a-half inches shorter your
muscle mass and bone density will
continue to decrease at a rapid pace and
for some women they still lead to
osteoporosis severe bone loss almost
every woman in her 40s will have weight
problems your muscle mass decreases and
your weight increases because of
hormonal changes so in to eat bigger
meals earlier in the day and have
smaller and lighter dinners the fit
woman in her 50s your body fat is
typically between 27 to 31 percent you
may experience some wear and tear in
your joints due to years of activities
you may want to rethink your exercise
routine and switch to lower impact
workouts such as swimming cycling and
minimize jump based exercises you will
also begin to lose skin elasticity and
have slight wrinkles on the face but
you're still able to fight against
gravity and your body still look amazing
the sedentary woman in her 50s your body
fat is too
between 33 to 37 percent if you still
continue to eat and eat by now your
weight should have increased by 7 to 10
kilos you might be diagnosed with high
blood pressure high cholesterol levels
and you're more susceptible to diseases
you'll have poor posture forward
sludging protruding stomach and over
arched lower back your skin wrinkles and
your body is started downward by gravity
noticeable saggy breasts tummy and
buttocks you may even have a noticeable
gray hairs you need about 30 percent
less energy in comparison to when you
were in your 20s so into eat four to
five smaller portions a day the fit
woman in her 60s your body fat is
typically between 28 to 31 percent as
you continue to stay active you're able
to maintain a healthy appetite
hence consuming enough calories to
maintain a healthy body weight and
preventing filty in all age despite
going through menopause your bones are
strong thanks to many years of strength
training you will have a slight wrinkles
about your skin is still glowing thanks
to all the good foods and exercise over
the years the sedentary woman in her 60s
your body fat is between a 34 to 38
percent by now you're 2 to 3 inches
shorter you'll begin to lose appetite
and you may not consume enough calories
to maintain a healthy body weight and
appear thrilled your breasts continue to
Sag and your waist and hips widen even
more wrinkles and now creases and your
skin is dry your heart will also weaken
by 10 to 15 percent and you're more
likely to be ill if you want to lose
weight you should do it very slowly
drastic drop in food intake can decrease
the protein in your muscle mass and also
bone mass the fit woman in her seventies
your body fat is typically between 31 to
34 percent you're able to move about
without any help and you can carry on
your daily routine without many
difficulties you have a strong body
heart and active
and you look and feel 20 years younger
you will have more wrinkles and dry
looking skin due to the decline in oil
production in your body after menopause
the sedentary woman in her 70s your body
fat is way over 38 percent your
movements are slow and you can't carry
on your daily routine without feeling
pain in your body or feeling exhausted
very quickly you may have high blood
pressure brittle bones and healthy
cholesterol levels and you're consuming
lots of different medications just to
keep your body going you have a very dry
skin lots of wrinkles hence making you
appear unhappy this illustration and
information are based on the average
woman who trains regularly and have a
normal modern day job if you are an
athlete then of course you will have low
body fat higher muscle mass and also
bone density longevity and aging
gracefully isn't about denying your age
it isn't just about how you good you
look at 50 or 60 but it is about how you
feel on the inside I know that I want to
feel strong energetic happy and be
healthy as I age and I want to be able
to look back at this video 30 years
later and say damn Johanna you still
look good and feel as energetic as in
your younger days so I want to share
with you a picture of my role model
someone I hope to become as I age
gracefully and I want you to guess her
age she's a close family member a
grandmother her hair isn't dyed it is
the way it is she goes for line dance
classes twice a week takes her daily
walks it mostly home-cooked food and
joys her sweet treats in moderation and
have a very positive outlook on life
despite the generation gap she's someone
that I can talk to relate to and I would
always visit her whenever I'm done in
London so I'm going to reveal her age in
the description box below but before you
look at it let me know your guess in the
comments below she has taught me that
aging is a privilege because it means
that you have lived a long and fulfilled
life and that's what I want for each and
every one of you if you enjoyed this
video if you find the illustrations to
be interesting - give it a thumb up
share it and subscribe to my youtube
channel for new weekly videos do also
watch the recommended videos right at
the end stay beautiful
you
you